angry crowds and democratic republic of
congo push towards the border with
rwanda they're chanting slogans against
the rwandan president paul kogami
it's too much now this provocation from
the people of rwanda it's not the first
time that we've seen the situation
the crowds had gathered after a
congolese soldier walked from the city
of gomer towards rwandan territory
firing his weapon rwandan soldiers shot
back two of them were injured the
congolese soldier was killed
and when his body was brought back
across the border the dead soldier was
given a hero's welcome
[Applause]
he expressed the courage of a real
soldier by giving his life defending the
respect and honour of our country we're
asking our government to support us so
that we can defend ourselves against
paul kagame and his people
people here blame the rwandan president
for a recent escalation of violence
between congolese forces and the m23
armed group dr congo accuses rwanda of
supporting funding and arming the group
something kigali denies
the analysts are very worried that the
m23 which has this extraordinary new
energy
and the congolese are certainly suspect
that rwanda is giving it new weapons new
arms
everyone is worried that it's going to
seize gomer
and that would change the balance of
power in the region
on wednesday thousands in gomer marched
towards the border ransacking shops and
searching cars suspected of carrying
rwandans
this mineral-rich frontier has been
unstable for decades but the u.n says
hate speech directed towards rwandans is
fueling mistrust between the communities
all of that more or less have created
has created quite the heated kind of uh
temperature that you have on congolese
streets today in goma or in bukavu
with people basically taking stones and
believing that they are able to go
across in rwanda and go to galilee and
basically take kagami by hand
dia congo is now limiting border
crossings its president felix cesar
khedi is accusing rwanda of trying to
occupy his land
military commanders are due to meet on
sunday to discuss the deployment of a
regional force to try to keep the peace
alexio brian al jazeera